الرتج هو هذا النوع من
الأكياس التي
يكون شكلها شائعًا جدًا في الواقع مع تقدمنا في ال
ن ، سيصاب الكثير منا با
عدوى أو الالتهاب الذي يكون التهاب ال
تج أقل شي
عًا ولكنه لم يس
ع به من قبل نرى هذا شائعًا جدًا في
سم ال
وارئ  والجراحة مرة أخرى
ليست غير شائعة خاصة في
البلاد الغربية يبدو أن هذا
يحدث أكثر وأكثر وهذا
الإجراء هو إجراء رئيسي هو
تخدير عام إنها عملية جراحية كبرى في البطن في
معظم الأحيان ما يفعلونه هو أنهم
في الواقع إزالة جزء من القولون
حيث توجد المشكلة ، لذلك
سيكون هناك تعافي كبير هنا
وهناك خطر على أساس العمر
ولكن في نفس الوقت حقيقة أن
هذه حالة طارئة ليست حالة
طارئة تم التخطيط لها
أمر جيد  الشيء الذي يقلل بالتأكيد من
المخاطر
ولكنه سيكون تعافيًا كبيرًا ،
كما تعلم كم من الوقت يصعب
تحديده وشخص أكبر سنًا سيكون
قليلًا  nger
هذا نوع مما نتوقعه مع
أي عملية جراحية كبرى هو هذا الشيء الذي
يتم اكتشافه أثناء
إجراء تنظير القولون المنتظم أو كيف
يمكن تشخيص شيء من هذا القبيل
حتى يتم تشخيص الرتج أو
تلك الأكياس التي يمكن
اكتشافها أثناء تنظير القولون العادي
تمامًا
في معظم الأوقات ، ما نراه على الأقل في
قسم الطوارئ هو أن المرضى
يأتون بألم في
البطن ونجد هذا بناءً على فحص القط ،
ونجد أن الالتهاب
هو السبب في ألم البطن ،
ويمكن أن تكون الأكياس الصغيرة التي تتكون منها بدون أعراض تمامًا في
كثير من الناس
لسنوات أو حتى عقود ، ولم يتم
العثور عليها إلا عند
إجراء تنظير القولون للفحص الروتيني ، وإذا
لم يكن لديهم التهاب ، فليس هناك الكثير
للقيام به ولكن عندما يحدث هذا الالتهاب في
بعض الأحيان ، يوصي الجراحون
بإجراء عملية جراحية
حتى لا يحدث ذلك.  لا تخلق المزيد من المشاكل
على طول الخط